مرحبًا ،
كيف حالك ،
ما الذي يحدث
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
هناك امرأة سوداء صغيرة
تمشي وترش أشياء على
الأرصفة والأشجار
في إليزابيث إلى فلورنسا.
أي وصف مثل الملابس
أو أي شيء آه ، إنها
امرأة صغيرة حقيقية حقيقية ، صغيرة جدًا ، نعم ،
لديها غطاء للرأس ، لا يمكنك أن تفوتها
تمامًا ،
كيف حالك
ما يحدث
هو أن والدتك
ما هذا
يا ما الذي تستخدمه لرعايتك
تحاول الإمساك به ،
هل هذه والدتك تنزل إلى الشارع ،
حسنًا ، اتصل شخص ما للتو وقال
إنها كانت بمفردها ترش شيئًا ما
على العشب ،
نعم ، حسنًا ، هل يمكنني الحصول على
معلوماتك ، أنا آسف جوزيف ، هل أنت
جاد ، نعم أعتقد أنه  رأيت ذلك ، لست
متأكدًا من
أنها استثمرت ، من الواضح أنها بخير ، فمن
الواضح أنك جيرانك المجاورون
لك حقًا لا لا ، أنت لست في مشكلة
كيف ذهبت كم عدد الأشجار التي قمت
بحفظها لأنها سيئة
[موسيقى]
إنها مياه  قالت وهي تصطاد ذباب الفانوس
إنها تعيش هنا ،
نعم ، إنها تصطاد ذباب الفانوس ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نرى سأراك لاحقًا
[موسيقى]
عنصرية متعمدة أم لا ،
أنا لست هنا لأصف أي شخص فقط
لمشاركة وجهة نظري باعتبارها
امرأة سوداء سوداء  أم ومقيمة من السود
في هذه المدينة ، فهي لا
تفعل شيئًا رائعًا فقط
لبيئتنا بل كانت تفعل شيئًا
جعلها تشعر وكأنها بطلة
أجنبية
[موسيقى]